this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon hey
crazies there's a question I get every
once in a while that I think we're ready
to answer what the heck is electric
charge let's just jump into it I don't
even think we'll need quantum mechanics
for this just like objects can have mass
or temperature or speed objects can also
have charge it's just a property things
like balloons hair or pieces of plastic
become charged by transferring electrons
supersu inside atoms protons and
neutrons are the heavier particles in
the center electrons are the lighter
looser particles on the outside so
they're what can get gained or lost when
things rub against each other if we rub
a balloon against someone's hair the
balloon and the hair become attracted to
each other now that they're charged they
don't even need to touch to affect each
other this is just like how masses
attract in Newtonian gravity we even
said in the previous video there were a
lot of similarities so this shouldn't be
a surprise if you're already subscribed
on like mass though charge has two
different types or flavors we call these
two types positive and negative but only
for mathematical convenience they're
just labels we could have just as easily
called them up and down or good and evil
or dingleberry and snozzberry the
snozzberries taste like snozzberries the
two types show opposite behaviors so as
long as the labels are opposites were
fine it doesn't even matter which ones
we label which the labels we use today
were decided two hundred and seventy
years ago in 1748 by Ben Franklin it
might have been better to label them the
other way but now we're stuck with it
thanks Ben Franklin hop on my filthy
back anyway where was I all right
opposite behaviour opposite charges
attract and like charges repel which i
think is pretty common knowledge at this
point that's what makes Adams the way
they are the protons are positive and
the electrons are negative so they're
attracted to each other unfortunately
since electrons are the things that move
around and electrons are negative I'm
gonna have to think backwards an
electron gain makes an object negative
and an electron loss makes
object positive the balloon from earlier
gained electrons from the hair so it
became negative and the hair became
positive but that doesn't really explain
what charge is as Cameron McHenry
pointed out sure objects become charged
because their parts are charged but
electrons are elementary particles they
don't have parts and neither do any of
these other charged particles so what
the heck is charge to answer that we
need to talk about the e/m field charge
in the electromagnetic field are
inextricably connected you can't really
understand one without understanding the
other what's a field again you know okay
but that's that's a fair question
a field is a value or set of values
assigned to every point in space but
jumping right into the e/m field could
be a bit overwhelming let's start with
gravity it's a little easier to imagine
and a lot easier to work with so here's
the earth just chillin around the earth
is a bunch of points in space and every
single one of those points has a vector
arrow attached to it since the earth is
pretty massive it is a lot of control
over those arrows the whole collection
of arrows is called a gravitational
field and it's always there even if
there isn't any mass around the field is
still there it's just zero it helps to
think of mass as a property of objects
in fields as a property of space the
earth and the space it occupies are real
tangible things the mass in the field
are just properties we measure to help
us explain what the tangible things are
doing in a really convenient way to
understand that connection is with
Gauss's law in general it's written like
this here's the field a property of
space and here's whatever property is
affecting that field for gravity it
relates the gravitational field to mass
it says the gravitational field across
some closed area also known as flux is
proportional to the mass inside that
closed area can you do that with a
picture please
oh yeah yeah sure thing let's imagine
that closed area is the surface of a
sphere if it's fear doesn't enclose any
mass then there's no flux across its
surface there is just as much field
pointed in as there is pointed out if
the sphere does enclose mass then
there's an overall inward flow
there's Moorefield pointed inward than
outward which is true no matter how big
the sphere is even if you don't know
where the mass is the fields behavior
tells you where the mass is and how much
there is it's actually a really useful
connection and because electricity is so
similar we can do the same thing with
the e/m field and charge but the en
field is just a smidge more complicated
we could look at it all together as the
electromagnetic tensor one big set of
numbers attached to each point in space
but it's easier to think about it as two
separate vectors instead one for the
electric part and one for the magnetic
part vector fields are so much easier
than tensor fields trust me you don't
want to use the tensors unless you have
to
so we'll imagine each point in space has
two vector arrows attached as the charge
moves around inside the space you can
see how each of those vectors changes if
the charge isn't moving then all the
magnetic arrows drop to zero leaving
only the electric arrows we'll focus on
the electric part now and save that
magnetic part for a later video
practicality for electric fields it
looks like this it relates the electric
field to charge and just like with
gravity you can use a carefully chosen
closed area to figure out where the
charge is and how much of it there is
just like mass tells us how much an
object or particle will affect the
gravitational field charge tells us how
much an object or particle will affect
the electromagnetic field
it's a coupling property it couples
objects and particles to space
so what's electric charge electric
charge is just a property of objects or
particles that inextricably connects
them to the e/m field and therefore to
space there are two opposite types that
display opposite behaviors it's
conserved across time and everyone
agrees how much there is it's a really
big deal so was that deep enough for you
or are you still craving the quantum
mechanics let us know in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
the featured comment comes from Zoltan
Kirti who mentioned Gauss didn't use
vector fields he use quarter neons yes I
know vectors weren't all that Universal
until Oliver Heaviside came along but
quarter neons are really confusing if
you're interested though three blue one
brown did a good video on them recently
link in the doobly-doo anyway thanks for
watching